yesterday the federal reserve chairman
jerome powell
he sat there like a punching bag and
lawmakers just got a tee off on them
they got to just ask
all of their questions and we learned a
whole bunch of different stuff we've
been talking about inflation nonstop as
i said yesterday inflation is the number
one topic in finance right now
whatever happens with the monetary
policy that is ultimately what's going
to drive it as you can see from this
amazing graphic
jerome powell ain't stopping man he's
just firing off the stimulus liquidity
he's going to keep
pumping the stock market everything is
going according to plan
but yesterday there was a couple of very
very interesting things that he said
first at one point he was asked about
employment and the federal reserve's
been talking a lot about using monetary
policy
to try to drive us closer to full
employment back in february of 2020 so
last year in february
we were about 3.5 unemployment that's a
historic
low um in in many regards
we today are at 5.9 unemployment
that is down drastically from where we
peaked last year in the double digits
but yesterday when asked about it jerome
powell said something
very interesting he said we're at 5.9
percent unemployment
but quote and the true number is
actually substantially higher than that
now wait a second here hold on
the head of the federal reserve is
telling us
that the official unemployment number is
wrong
the official number is wrong that's what
he just said he said the true number is
substantially higher than that
what is going on if we can't agree
on the actual number how does anyone
make
a decision if you have bad data inputs
you can't make sound decisions so what
is the true unemployment number is it
six percent which is only point one off
is it
sixteen percent is it ten percent is it
eight percent
is it something else what is the
unemployment number the chair of the
federal reserve who is
tasked with making monetary policy
decisions based on the data
is telling us that he doesn't believe
the data so why should the rest of us
care what the official unemployment
number is if they say it's 5.9
but the chair of the federal reserve
says no the true number is actually
substantially higher
how much higher why is that the official
number and now there's an unofficial
number
what is going on in the world now we may
just
when they start talking about official
numbers we should just call them
inaccurate numbers
so every time that somebody says oh the
official unemployment number what we
should say is no the inaccurate
unemployment number is 5.9 percent why
is it inaccurate because the real number
is much higher the chair of the federal
reserve just told us that
what i do find very funny is that they
never
ever ever give an official number where
they miss to the upside
meaning oh we've reported 5.9
unemployment but we believe it to be
lower
it's always that somehow the official
numbers are lower
than what would actually be the truth
and that's
presenting the data in a much more
positive light
this is absolutely freaking nonsense
but now that the chair of the federal
reserve has come out and made it
explicitly clear that he does not
believe the data
everything he's saying all the official
numbers he doesn't believe it he thinks
the true number is substantially higher
that leads us to believe is it just
unemployment numbers or are there other
numbers
that maybe we shouldn't believe as well
so we've got a chart here
of the inflation data and if we think
about inflation
that seems to be a pretty big topic
right now in the red we have the
official cpi
number and that's uh sitting right
around that four and a half
uh percent core inflation five point
four percent cpi number
but the blue line is an alternative data
set that comes from shadow stats there's
plenty of people who try to figure out
what's the real
inflation number they're estimating that
it's somewhere around nine percent
so if the unemployment numbers the
official unemployment numbers are
inaccurate and it's the true number is
substantially higher
is it possible that the true inflation
number is
inaccurate or the true number is
substantially higher as well
probably is it eight nine ten percent
i don't know but they don't know either
and that's the point
is that the federal reserve is making
monetary policy decisions off
inaccurate data they're now admitting to
it and nobody
knows what the real numbers are so all
of this kind of
charade that is going on where jerome
powell and politicians and the treasury
everyone is trying to play intellectual
nobody knows
we're just saying that we don't know i
don't know what the true inflation
number is
i don't know what the true unemployment
number is and neither do they
and that scares the hell out of me and
it should scare the hell out of you
that we have people making monetary
policy decisions and they don't know the
true data
that is absurd now if we go and we look
at other things that jerome powell said
yesterday i mean this was literally the
one of the most comical
conferences and kind of questionings
that i've seen in a long time
they said hey you now are admitting that
you don't know what the true
unemployment number is
obviously inflation is this highly
controversial topic uh
there is a woman karen petrue who i've
had on the podcast before
who wrote a recent op-ed and uh one of
the representatives uh i think it was
richie torres
uh said listen that op-ed suggests that
the federal reserve is responsible for
wealth inequality and is driving wealth
inequality
and so uh when asked about it here's a
couple of the things that jerome powell
had to
say and brace yourself because this is
absurd
literally three quotes i don't agree
with that assessment
fine you disagree the next the poor in
the working class
never came in and said wow you should
really raise interest rates because you
are increasing inequality and then
lastly literally
never hear that from them so wait a
second
is the sitting chairman of the federal
reserve suggesting
that the federal reserve and their
monetary policy decisions
have zero implications in the wealth
inequality gap being widened
as they've created all this monetary
stimulus because
poor and working class individuals
haven't
showed up in their office and told them
hey you're making the walton equality
gap wider
these people are unhinged if you think
that they literally believe this they've
never heard
somebody in the poor of the working
class tell them that their decisions
are making their lives worse and
therefore the federal reserve must not
actually be
uh creating any sort of negative
situation i literally i would laugh at
this
if it wasn't so arrogant and sad now
what's
hilarious to me is why all of this is
going on and we have
overwhelming data that shows that the
federal reserve is the
greatest driver of wealth inequality in
our country through their monetary
policy decisions
stanley druckenmiller one of the best
investors ever on wall street who's been
on cnbc
multiple times saying that he believes
the federal reserve is the greatest
driver of wealth and equality over the
last decade or so
at the same time all this is happening
jerome powell
was literally taking a photo shoot for a
magazine
this is a photo that jerome powell
literally took recently
like what is going on we have millions
and millions and millions of
americans in this country who literally
are worse off now than they were a year
ago because of this man and his
organizations monetary policy decisions
but he had time to do a photo shoot get
out of here
right and then he's got the balls to
literally say
two representatives when they're
questioning him oh we have nothing to do
with wealth inequality because i've
never heard a poor portion tell me that
we do
there is nothing more elitist than
watching
a guy in a suit and tie sit there
and literally just gaslight an entire
country
the man who by the way is worth
an estimated of at least 50 million or
more he's by far the richest board of
governors at the federal reserve
and has probably profited more than
anybody else inside the federal reserve
due to these policies
because most of his assets are actually
in investments rather than holding it in
cash
is going to gaslight an entire country
it's absurd to listen to this
if that wasn't bad enough we then
had questions around stable coins and
somebody asked
him if we actually get a digital dollar
what do you think
and he had this to say you wouldn't need
stable coins and you wouldn't need
cryptocurrencies
if you had a digital us currency now
jerome powell is a very intelligent guy
jerome powell has had a very successful
career
on wall street in finance before he took
over as the the federal reserve chairman
he also knows exactly what he's saying
here there are two problems
with the us dollar today the first is a
monetary policy problem where they
continue to devalue the currency at a
historic rate
the second is a technology problem where
literally countries in africa have
better payment infrastructure through
mobile banking
than we have here in the united states
where the federal reserve and the
government is working on the fed now
payment system is supposed to be this
really slick thing but it's not going to
be available for years
into the future so a monetary policy
problem we have a technology problem
if you digitize the dollar it only
solves
the technology problem you create a
better piece of technology
it doesn't address the monetary policy
all you are doing is you're simply
putting lipstick on a pig you're
digitizing the technology
what jerome powell forgets to mention or
is ignorant to is the fact that people
are worse off now than they were a year
ago because of the monetary policy
nobody is complaining about the
technology
they're talking about crypto currencies
because
of the monetary policy superiority and
so
if you digitize the dollar all you are
doing is you're simply making
it a little bit cheaper a little bit
faster for payments that is a
evolutionary improvement it's important
they should do that
that will improve the technology but the
revolutionary
improvement the leap forward the
inflection point in terms of the wealth
of a nation
comes from the monetary policy
improvement
and if you look at a federal reserve
central bank of the united states
that is not independent because our
government
can order them to change the monetary
policy
and on top of that you see things around
uh the lack of predictability we have no
clue what they're gonna do in the future
they had two emergency rate cuts last
year completely unpredicted not only
were the decisions unpredictable
but the timing of the decisions were
unpredictable because that's why they're
called emergency rate cuts
so in order to have a central bank that
is competent
and effective you need to have two key
components you need
to be independent and you need that uh
central bank
to be predictable right to be dependent
to be reliable
we have neither one of those in the
united states today and so instead what
happens is something like bitcoin
where it is fully decentralized there's
nothing more independent than a
decentralized system that no one owns
and no one controls right
bitcoin is the most independent central
bank in the world
the second thing that it has is it has
full predictability there is no central
bank monetary policy in the world that
is more predictable
than bitcoin why it's because it's
programmatic and transparent
we know exactly what's going to happen
when it's going to happen it's in the
code you can verify yourself you don't
need a man in a suit and a tie to tell
you what he's going to do
and so when we look at the totality of
what happened yesterday
i'm worried i'm legitimately worried
if you are sitting in cash i was already
worried
but like now i'm actually scared and it
reaffirmed my belief
as to why bitcoin is going to continue
to get adoption
because we have a guy who literally is
telling us that the official metrics
that he uses to make decisions he
doesn't even believe
he's telling us that he doesn't believe
that he has any impact on wealth and
equality because a poor person didn't
come up to him and tell him
and then if it make it even worse he
then somehow thinks that by changing the
technology around his currency
he's going to address the problem of the
monetary policy
i literally don't know anymore at this
point what they're thinking or how this
works but this is completely unhinged
my favorite part before we get joe and
john's opinion is
i had to google today where the federal
reserve building was
and i pulled it up and i just have this
image in my head
of somebody going to this building and
asking at the front desk
saying uh i would like to speak to mr
powell please i am
a victim of the wealth inequality gap
and i would like to explain to him that
his interest rate decisions and his
quantitative easing participation has
pushed me into a further
dire financial position do you believe
that he is available for a 15-minute
meeting today
that's what he wants us to do he
literally is advocating for the fact
that the only way that he is going to
recognize that he is contributing to the
wealth and equality in our country is if
you go to his building
and you come into his office and you
tell him hey dude
you keep manipulating the interest rate
and it's pushing me further and further
into poverty i live paycheck to paycheck
along with 78 of americans
78 of americans live paycheck to
paycheck you're sitting here and you're
just
throwing cash around like it's not
valuable
well you've completely devalued the
currency over the last 12 months
why are you doing this i know joe
was dying laughing when he just heard
some of this yesterday
i was dying laughing at the picture of
him that looks like he's in gq